This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历另一面后，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 TWO. percent。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方真的不安全，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。
Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the podcast. world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, let's cut straight to the chase. I want to talk about creative passion projects, creative side hustles, creative hobbies, the things that we are called to deeply create and express and make, and basically how to find a balance between making time for creation, in our busy world and also needing to work, needing to pay our bills. How do we find the balance between practicality and passion?
欢迎回到本播客。新听众、老听众，无论你在播客世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的另一期节目，我们在节目中剖析20多岁时的心理学。今天，让我们直奔主题。我想谈谈创作激情项目、创意副业、创意爱好，那些我们被召唤去深深创造、表达和制造的事物，以及基本上如何在忙碌的世界中为创作腾出时间与需要工作、需要支付账单之间找到平衡。我们如何在实用主义和激情之间找到平衡？
How can we hold both of these things at once without feeling like our creative endeavors are always the first thing to basically be sacrificed? I get so many questions about this, specifically from obviously people in their 20s who are facing this dilemma of do I pursue the thing that I'm really passionate about, some creative act, some entrepreneurial idea, or do I stick with what is expected of me, what is very traditional, what is very stable? And specifically, the questions I often get are around how we can turn our passions into our jobs, when to take the risk and pursue whatever it is you want to pursue, art, music, writing,
我们如何能同时兼顾这两件事，而不会觉得我们的创意努力总是基本上首先被牺牲掉的东西？我收到了很多关于这方面的问题，特别是显然来自那些正面临着这种困境的20多岁的人：我是去追求我真正热衷的事情、某个创意行为、某个创业想法，还是坚持那些对我有所期望的、非常传统的、非常稳定的东西？特别是，我经常收到的问题是关于我们如何将激情转化为工作，何时去冒风险去追求你想要追求的任何东西——艺术、音乐、写作、
podcasting full time, but also so many DMs asking me for time management. strategies, how to deal with creative blocks, how to know when financially you are ready to pursue your creative passion full time. So I really thought that it deserved its own episode because I can speak really deeply to this from experience. If you are new to the show and you don't know the origin story of the psychology of your 20s, this podcast started all the way back in 2021, so almost four years ago. And when I first started it, I wasn't working. I was fun-employed. Basically, I was convinced I was going to take a gap year. And then I ended up working in a corporate job for around a year and a half, almost two years, whilst I was doing the podcast full-time
全职做播客，但也有很多私信向我询问时间管理策略、如何应对创作瓶颈、如何在财务上知道自己何时准备好全职追求创意激情。所以我真的认为它值得拥有自己的一期节目，因为我可以从经验中非常深刻地谈论这一点。如果你是这个节目的新听众，不知道《20多岁心理学》的起源故事，这个播客早在2021年就开始了，所以差不多是四年前。当我刚开始做这个节目时，我没有工作。我处于快乐的失业状态。基本上，我确信我要去过一个间隔年。然后我最终在一份公司的工作中做了大约一年半，差不多两年，同时我还在全职做播客。
as well. So I was working a full-time job and I was putting out this show and I was, I don't know, I don't like to say building the platform. The show was just growing. as I poured more love into it, basically. And at some point, I had to basically make the decision. Do I leave the steadiness and the stability, especially the financial stability of my full-time job for the podcast, or do I kind of just, you know, continue to make my side hustle? And I really found that every single day,
我也是。所以我做着一份全职工作，同时推出这个节目，而且我，我不知道，我不太喜欢说建立平台。随着我倾注更多的爱，这个节目自然而然地成长了，基本上就是这样。在某个时刻，我不得不做出决定。我是为了播客而放弃我全职工作的平稳和稳定，特别是财务稳定性，还是只是，你知道的，继续经营我的副业？我真的发现每一天，
I was so excited to get home and just work on the podcast. And I really didn't care about work anymore. And it was just impossible to hold, both of those things at once. So I decided to quit my job and to pursue what, you know, is a creative passion for me. Like podcasting is actually a real creative force and there's so much creativity and inspiration involved in coming up with ideas. I find the research to be quite a fun process.
我回到家里都兴奋得只想做播客。我真的不在乎工作了。同时兼顾这两件事是不可能的。所以我决定辞掉工作，去追求对我来说是创意激情的东西。就像播客其实是一种真正的创作力量，在构思点子时涉及如此多的创造力和灵感。我发现做研究是一个相当有趣的过程。
So I want to really talk about what I learned from that experience and how you can maybe take my story and elements of it and apply it to your own journey with your creative project or passion. And maybe the goal for you is to make that passion into a full-time career. Maybe it's not. I think regardless, this episode will have a lot for you. I also want to discuss some of the many barriers, hurdles, boundaries that we kind of clash against in this space. When we as someone who is creative and passionate about something and doing something quite artistic with our free time, you know, there's going to be a lot of loud forces and voices telling you that you can't do it or, you know, voices from within doubting yourself, imposter syndrome,
所以我真的很想谈谈我从那次经历中学到了什么，以及你如何能借鉴我的故事和其中的一些元素，并将其应用到你自己的创意项目或激情的旅程中。也许你的目标是将这种激情变成全职职业。也许不是。我认为无论如何，这期节目都会有很多适合你的内容。我还想讨论我们在这一领域面临的许多障碍、跨栏、界限。当我们作为一个对某事充满创造力和热情、并在空闲时间内做一些相当具艺术性的事情的人时，你知道，会有很多嘈杂的力量和声音告诉你，你做不到，或者，你知道的，来自内心的怀疑自己的声音、冒名顶替综合症、
artistic blocks, also things like money and time, there is a real limit sometimes on to where our creative passion can take us because of these boundaries and barriers. So I really want to use this episode to basically teach you how you can use psychology to take yourself from a place of perfectionism and fear, really to a place of creation and abundance and consistency. I'm very, very excited for this episode. Some of the research and the studies surrounding this is just fascinating. There is this whole area of psychological research. research that is focused on creativity and how we as humans practice it and also on how we make
艺术瓶颈，还有诸如金钱和时间之类的事情，由于这些界限和障碍，我们的创意激情有时能带我们去到哪里是有限度的。所以我真的想利用这期节目来教你如何利用心理学，让自己从完美主义和恐惧的地方，真正走向创造、丰盛和持续性。我对这期节目感到非常非常兴奋。围绕这一主题的一些研究和调查简直令人着迷。这里有一个完整的心理学研究领域。研究重点是创造力，我们人类如何实践它，以及我们如何从中谋生，这又对这种关系产生了什么影响。
a living out of it and what that does to the relationship. So there is a lot to look forward to. Without further ado, let's get into it. So you want to put your creative passion basically at the center of your life. That's probably why you are listening to this podcast. And let me just firstly say that is amazing. That is amazing. I am fully supportive of this decision. I don't even know you and I still think it's a great idea. But before we talk about how to make this possible, let's talk about some of the difficulties that you might encounter or that you probably already have because I think they bear mentioning and let's just get them out of the way. Let's get the fear part out of the way. So the first big worrying thing that I think we encounter is naysayers.
所以有很多值得期待的事情。废话不多说，我们开始吧。所以你想把你的创意激情放在你生活的中心。这可能就是你收听这个播客的原因。首先让我说这太棒了。这太棒了。我全力支持这个决定。我甚至都不认识你，但我仍然认为这是一个好主意。但在我们讨论如何使之成为可能之前，让我们先谈谈你可能会遇到的一些困难，或者你可能已经遇到过的困难，因为我认为它们值得一提，让我们把它们抛开。让我们把恐惧的部分抛开。所以我们遇到的第一个令人担忧的大问题是唱反调的人。
Neaysayers, people who are pessimistic about your journey, pessimistic about your chances of success. there is always, always going to be someone who does not believe in you, who says that you should be more careful. You should be more realistic. Maybe it's a parent. Maybe it's a partner. They'll call your ambitions, you know, cute. Or they obviously don't think you're capable.
唱反调的人，对你的旅程悲观的人，对你成功几率悲观的人。总会有，总会有人不相信你，说你应该更小心点。你应该更现实一点。也许是父母。也许是伴侣。他们会把你的野心称为，你知道的，可爱。或者他们显然认为你没有能力。
Maybe it's someone online, of someone who calls themselves a friend. I know that sometimes these people, if we give them the benefit of the doubt, are genuinely worried about you. But don't let their doubts become. your own. I think that for every person who does believe in you, there's always going to be that one person who has to voice every concern they have, or worse yet, who actively really does try to bring you down, truly, you know, gives you all their judgment and makes it your burden. And I really want to tell you right now, pay those judgments no mind at all. Because often, if this is someone
也许是网络上的某个人，一个自称朋友的人。我知道有时这些人，如果我们给他们一些信任的话，是真的为你担心。但不要让他们的怀疑变成你自己的。我认为对于每一个相信你的人来说，总会有那么一个人，他必须说出他所有的担忧，或者更糟糕的是，他积极地真的试图把你拉下来，真的，你知道的，把他们所有的评判都给你，并把它变成你的负担。我真的现在就要告诉你，对这些评判完全不要放在心上。因为通常情况下，如果这个人
who does not know you or care about you, it is a massive projection and refaq. And, of what they are feeling internally about their own capabilities and their own dreams. You know, the people who I've encountered who have the most and the worst things to say and who did have the worst things to say about my own journey to quit my full-time job through the podcast full-time, most of them actually had grand ambitions of their own that they had abandoned. And, you know, those are the people who expressed the most doubt about my goals. because I think somewhere deep down, they kind of wanted me to quit. They wanted me to join them in this boat.
是不认识你或不关心你的人，这是对他们内心对自身能力和自身梦想的感觉的一种巨大的投射和重新包装。你知道的，我遇到的那些有最多、最糟糕的话要说的人，以及那些对我自己通过播客全职辞去全职工作的旅程有过最糟糕的话要说的人，他们大多数人实际上自己也有他们已经放弃的宏伟野心。而且，你知道，这些人是对我的目标表现出最多怀疑的人，因为我认为在内心深处的某处，他们某种程度上希望我放弃。他们希望我加入他们的这条船。
This boat filled with people who, for whatever reason, and many of them were good reasons, but they'd given up on their artistic creative dreams. So this idea that naysayers are projecting their own insecurities around their inability to follow their passions, there is proof of this. And the proof for this comes from a study from the University of Alaska, which, examined 210 individuals and found that those who self-reported higher levels of insecurity, they were more likely to openly criticize the work of others. And not only were they more likely to criticize, their criticisms were harsher than other peoples. And often, this is the very important
这条船上坐满了人，无论出于什么原因（其中许多原因很好），但他们已经放弃了他们的艺术创意梦想。所以这种认为唱反调的人在投射他们自己对无法追随激情的 insecurities（不安全感）的观点，是有证据支持的。这一点的证据来自阿拉斯加大学的一项研究，该研究调查了210名个人，发现那些自我报告有更高程度不安全感的人，更有可能公开批评别人的工作。不仅他们更有可能批评，而且他们的批评比其他人更严厉。而且通常，这是非常重要的一部分。
part, often the people they were most critical of were those whose work they thought was better than their own. So this is describing something called ego defense in psychology. Sometimes, often we criticize others as a way of protecting our ego from feeling devalued. You know, so even if my work sucks, if I can convince myself and convince someone else, that their work also sucks and sucks more, well, then I won't feel so bad. Do not listen to them. my saying is always prove them wrong with a smile in your face and that is kind of
部分是，他们最挑剔的人往往是那些他们认为工作比自己更好的人。这在心理学中描述了一种叫做自我防御（ego defense）的东西。有时，通常我们批评别人是为了保护我们的 ego（自我）免受贬低感的影响。你知道，所以即使我的工作很烂，如果我能说服自己并说服别人，他们的工作也很烂，而且更烂，那么我就不会感觉那么糟糕了。不要听他们的。我的说法是，永远带着微笑用事实证明他们是错的，这可以说是
the sweetest revenge. I think everyone says you can't until you do and then suddenly they will say that they were your best friend. They suddenly have always believed in you but you have to know that you believed in yourself the whole time and you were doing it because you loved it because
最甜蜜的复仇。我想每个人都说你做不到，直到你做到了，然后突然间他们会说他们是你最好的朋友。他们突然一直都相信你，但你必须知道你一直以来都相信自己，你这样做是因为你热爱它，因为
you felt like you could rise above all of this judgment, all of these doubts and just do it yourself. So naysayers, that's a big one. Another big barrier to pursuing our creative passion, whether it's full time or part time or in our spare time, is lacking inspirational motivation. This is otherwise known as writer's block, creative block, artistic block. I think we've all come across this in some capacity. You know, you really want to make something. You finally have the time to do it. You've devoted time to your craft. You're, you're, you've devoted time to your craft.
你觉得你可以超越所有这些评判、所有这些怀疑，自己去做到。所以唱反调的人，这是一个大问题。追求我们创意激情的另一个巨大障碍，无论是全职、兼职还是在业余时间，都是缺乏灵感动机。这也就是所谓的作家瓶颈、创意瓶颈、艺术瓶颈。我想我们都以某种能力遇到过这种情况。你知道，你真的很想创造点东西。你终于有时间去做了。你已经为你的手艺投入了时间。你，你，你已经为你的手艺投入了时间。
you're sitting down in front of the blank page and nothing is coming to you. So to understand why this happens and why so often we can sit there and say, you know, I just want a big idea. I want to make something huge. I want to have this, you know, big thing come to my mind. We have to understand how the brain really plays a role in creativity. So at the forefront of our creativity is the prefrontal cortex. You hear about this a lot.
你坐在空白的页面前，什么灵感也没有。所以要理解为什么会这样，为什么我们经常可以坐在那里说，你知道，我只想要一个宏大的点子。我想创造一些巨大的东西。我想让这个，你知道的，巨大的东西来到我的脑海里。我们必须了解大脑在创造力中真正扮演的角色。处于我们创造力最前沿的是前额叶皮层。你经常听到这个。
it's basically the biggest cortex it's right at the front and it's responsible for decision making abstract thinking and that is really what generates new ideas that and this other area of the brain called the default mode network this is what is used during introspection and daydreaming and these areas collaborate with our executive network to basically take an idea that we've had that's very, you know, abstract and not quite tangible and make it into something. However, when we are stressed, when our cognitive resources are drained by work, by our busy lives, by financial stress, by pushing ourselves too hard for too long, those areas of the brain are overwhelmed. And stress is the biggest factor in this because it really constrains what is meant to be a free exploration of ideas.
它基本上是最大的皮层，就在正前方，负责决策、抽象思维，这正是产生新想法的原因，还有大脑的另一个区域，叫做默认模式网络（default mode network）。这是在内省和白日梦期间使用的区域，这些区域与我们的执行网络合作，基本上把我们拥有的一个非常抽象、不太具体的主意变成某种东西。然而，当我们感到压力时，当我们的认知资源被工作、忙碌的生活、财务压力、把自己推得太狠太久而耗尽时，大脑的这些区域就会不堪重负。压力是其中的最大因素，因为它确实限制了本该是对想法的自由探索。
and it stifles creative risk-taking, but stress also just basically shuts down the creative parts of our brain because, you know, we do have limited cognitive resources. And if there is some bigger pressing thing in our life that is causing emotional distress or chaos or overwhelming us, our brain's going to say, let's focus on that first and we can get to the creativity later. You know, I like to think of this as like a business going through financial strife. the first like departments that are cut anytime you see a business failing are going to be the creative departments it's going to be the areas that hire artists and freethinkers and marketers and all those things and your brain is operating on that same like weirdly economic principle but also maybe the brain
它扼杀了创造性的冒险，但压力也基本上关闭了我们大脑中富有创造力的部分，因为，你知道的，我们确实有有限的认知资源。如果我们的生活中有什么更紧迫的事情正在导致情感困惑或混乱或让我们不知所措，我们的大脑会说，让我们先专注于那个，我们可以稍后再谈创造力。你知道，我喜欢把这想象成一个经历财务困境的企业。任何时候你看到一个企业倒闭，最先被砍掉的部门往往是创意部门，将是那些雇佣艺术家、自由思想家、营销人员所有这些人的领域，而你的大脑正以那种同样奇怪的经济原则运作，但也可能大脑
like these systems came first chicken and egg problem basically your brain is saying creativity is a luxury we can't afford right now so here's what you need to prioritize in those moments and it's not creation It's not pushing yourself harder. It's getting back to basics, taking care of yourself. And that might mean not creating for a while, but putting all that time and energy that you would spend worrying about not creating and not doing enough into getting outdoors, into cooking yourself nutritious food, getting eight hours of sleep,
像这些系统最先出现，基本上是个鸡生蛋蛋生的问题。你的大脑在说创造力是我们现在负担不起的奢侈品，所以这是你在那些时刻需要优先考虑的事情。不是创造。不是把自己推得更狠。而是回到基础，照顾好自己。这可能意味着一段时间不创造，而是把你会花在担心自己没有创造和做得不够上的所有时间和精力，投入到走到户外、给自己做营养丰富的食物、睡八小时觉中去，
moving your body in ways that you like, hydrating. And more importantly, addressing those bigger stresses that are demanding your attention. and then once you have those basic needs, then you can add novelty. Novelty is the secret source of inspiration and creativity and everything that comes out of that. You need new, novel, fresh experiences to bring about fresh ideas. Simple, very, very simple. But I think a lot of the time we feel like we're never going to be inspired again. Or we put ourselves in environments, mental and physical, that don't allow for.
以你喜欢的方式活动身体，补充水分。更重要的是，解决那些需要你注意的更大压力。然后，一旦你有了这些基本需求，你就可以加入新奇感。新奇感是灵感和创造力的秘密源泉，以及由此产生的一切。你需要新的、新颖的、新鲜的体验来带来新鲜的想法。很简单，非常非常简单。但我认为很多时候我们觉得我们再也不会有灵感了。或者我们把自己置于精神上和身体上不允许的环境中。
for inspiration because they're too restrictive. So if you're finding that you're having a creative artistic idea block, go out and explore and be inspired and then come back. It's like anytime I go on holiday, I always, and I'm like, I'll go on holiday and I'll say to myself, all right, we're not going to work. Like no work, two weeks off and suddenly I have like every single amazing idea that I've ever had. That is really, you know, your brain finally being able to relax and making space for that. I'm kind of going on with these barriers, but I want to talk about this last one. because it's probably the biggest and it's money and time. If we only had a million dollars, if we only had 48 hours in every day,
因为它们太限制了，所以无法获得灵感。所以如果你发现自己遇到了创意艺术想法的瓶颈，那就出去探索并获得灵感，然后回来。就像我每次去度假一样，我总是，我好像会去度假，然后对自己说，好吧，我们不工作。就像不工作，休假两周，突然间我有了一种有生以来最棒的想法。这实际上是，你知道的，你的大脑终于能够放松并为之腾出空间。我有点在讨论这些障碍，但我想谈谈最后一个。
we would have so much more time to put towards our creative entrepreneurial endeavors. You know, I think every single creative person I know struggles with this balancing act between necessity and passion. You know, you want to spend all of your time, focus. on whatever you're working on, but you have to work. You have to make money. It's a real privilege, really, to be able to devote yourself full time to your creative passion. It's a luxury that not many of us have, but I want to say that doesn't mean that you're not serious and committed to what you're doing. There are so many people who find ways to fit their creative passions around the
因为这可能是最大的一个，那就是金钱和时间。如果我们有一百万美元，如果我们每天只有48小时，我们将有更多的时间投入到我们的创意创业努力中。你知道，我认为我认识的每一个有创意的人都在与这种必要性和激情之间的平衡行为作斗争。你知道，你想把所有的精力和时间。花在你正在从事的任何事情上，但你必须工作。你必须赚钱。能够全身心投入到你的创意激情中，这真的是一种特权。这不是我们许多人都有的奢侈品，但我想说这并不意味着你对你正在做的事情不够认真和投入。有很多人找到了在生活中
necessities of their life. You know, some ways that I've seen people do this. This is how I did it. I worked part time but it was it was nine days a fortnight so instead of 10 days of fortnight I just took a day off every two weeks because I really couldn't afford to do anything more than that and I would spend that extra day and I'd turn it into a long weekend and I would have time that would be devoted to creation you know if you can do three four days a week and have even more time for it that's even better devoting one day of the weekend to your creative job or creative passion. I actually have a friend and I really love that she does this. She read an article, I remember her telling me about this,
必要性周围适应他们创意激情的方法。你知道，我看到人们这样做的一些方法。这就是我做的方式。我做兼职，但那是两周九天，所以不是两周十天，我每两周只是请一天假，因为我真的负担不起做更多的事情，我会把那多出来的一天变成一个长周末，我会拥有用于创作的时间，你知道的，如果你能一周做三、四天，并且有更多的时间去做，那就更好了。在周末留出一天给你的创意工作或创意激情。我其实有一个朋友，我真的很喜欢她这样做。她读了一篇文章，我记得她跟我说过这个，
she read this article a little while back about mini retirements. So instead of waiting to your 65 to retire, there's this whole group of people who do infrequent retirement chapters of their life. So they'll work really hard for a couple of years. years and then they will retire for six months and go and travel or do something creative or put that time into their business or whatever it is that they're doing. And it's kind of like an alternative to just waiting till, you know, you're perhaps less able and a bit older to do all the things that you wanted throughout your life. She works really, really hard for six months. And when I say really hard,
她前段时间读了这篇关于迷你退休的文章。所以，与其等到65岁才退休，不如有一群人他们会做不频繁的退休生活章节。所以他们会努力工作几年，然后他们会退休六个月去旅行或者做点有创意的事情，或者把时间投入到他们的业务中，或者他们正在做的任何事情。这有点像等待，你知道的，也许你体力不那么好、年纪稍微大一点时再去完成你一生中想做的事情的一种替代方案。她非常非常努力地工作六个月。当我指非常努力时，
she works three jobs at once. And then she takes two to three months off to paint and to go to artistic or creative retreats. So there are ways to do this and you are, I really want to stress you are no less creative because you have to put your ideas aside every now and again. You are no less capable of realizing your creative passion because you have to work a job. You know, because you have to work a job you're not passionate about to make money to do what you're really passionate about in your free time. Like sometimes I feel like we think we're cheating or we're failing at being a creative
她同时做三份工作。然后她休假两到三周去画画，去参加艺术或创意静修。所以是有方法做到这一点的，而你，我真的想强调，你并没有因为不得不时不时地把你的想法搁置一边而变得不那么有创意。你并没有因为必须找一份工作而减少实现创意激情的可能性。你知道，因为你必须做一份你并不热衷的工作来赚钱，以便在空闲时间做你真正热爱的事情。有时候我觉得我们觉得自己好像在作弊，或者作为创意人员我们失败了。
person. I don't think the creativity and that spirit ever goes away. I think it's something that we hold deep in us, even as necessity really calls. So if you're in that position or you're afflicted by some of those aforementioned barriers, let's really get into these five tips I have for you today for pursuing your creative passion. Let's start with possibly the most important one in my mind, which is don't focus on perfection, focus on just making something in any form, even if someone else is doing it better. I was talking to someone recently, we were seated next to each other at this dinner, about this business that they really want to launch. And I'm not going to give up her business idea because it's very, very smart. But she kept hitting this roadblock. She was telling me
我不认为创造力和那种精神会消逝。我认为这是我们深深持有的东西，即使在必要性真正呼唤的时候也是如此。所以如果你处于那种位置，或者受到上述某些障碍的困扰，让我们真正进入我今天为你准备的追求创意激情的五个技巧中。让我们从我心目中可能最重要的一点开始，那就是不要专注于完美，专注于以任何形式创造一些东西，即使别人做得更好。我最近和一个人聊天，我们在这次晚宴上座位挨着，谈到她真的很想推出的这个业务。我不会放弃她的业务想法，因为它非常非常聪明。但她一直遇到这个路障。她在告诉我
there was this mental roadblock that kept coming up for her, which was that she wasn't ready to fully announced this brilliant thing she'd been working on for years, unless it was entirely perfect. Because if it wasn't perfect, she was going to fail. So she kept taking a few more months, a few more months, a few more months, a few more months to really work on it. You know, timing had to be right. Her product had to have zero faults. And maybe you can guess where this story is going, but by the time she was ready to launch, someone else had already done it. And they had in her mind done it better. And she really fell into what I call the perfectionism fallacy. And this is a cognitive bias or a mistaken belief that something is either perfect or it is
有一个不断涌现的心智路障，那就是她还没有准备好全面宣布这个她已经为之努力了多年的绝妙东西，除非它是完全完美的。因为如果它不完美，她就会失败。所以她一直多花几个月，多花几个月，多花几个月，多花几个月来真正完善它。你知道，时机必须对。她的产品必须零瑕疵。也许你能猜到这个故事的结局，但当她准备好推出时，别人已经做过了。而且在她看来别人做得更好。她真的陷入了我所谓的完美主义谬误。这是一种认知偏差或错误信念，即某事要么是完美的，要么就是
worthless. And anything that is not perfect is entirely unacceptable. Does not deserve to be seen, does not deserve to be acknowledged. This belief really afflety. those of us who have a real deep sense of failure, who really adopt a lot of all or nothing thinking, who have a lot of excessive negative self-talk. It also affects those of us who have often tied our worth to tangible achievements. So I'm thinking, you know, our classic overachievers, gifted children, straight-A students, creative endeavors are often really difficult for people like us because there is no rules for what is good and bad. There's no grading scheme.
毫无价值的。任何不完美的东西都是完全不可接受的。不值得被看到，不值得被承认。这种信念真正折磨着。我们这些有深刻失败感、真正采纳了全或无思维、有很多过度的消极自我对话的人。它也影响了我们这些经常将自己的价值与具体成就绑定在一起的人。所以我在想，你知道，我们典型的过度成就者、天才儿童、全A学生，对像我们这样的人来说，创意努力往往非常困难，因为对于什么是好什么是坏没有规则。没有评分方案。
There's no way to tell if you're doing well. And even if someone says, you know, wow, I really like your art. I really like your music. I'm really inspired by you. I think you're amazing. We still have this tendency to not believe them because we can really see all of our faults. You know, we can see every tiny mistake that they have missed. You know, that's what the spotlight effect is in psychology.
没有办法判断你是否做得好。即使有人说，你知道，哇，我真的很喜欢你的艺术。我真的很喜欢你的音乐。我真的很受你启发。我觉得你太棒了。我们仍然有不相信他们的倾向，因为我们能清楚地看到我们所有的缺点。你知道，我们可以看到他们错过的每一个微小的错误。你知道，这就是心理学中的聚光灯效应（spotlight effect）。
it feels like there is this big mental beam shining down on every thing that is not perfect and can't everyone else see it you know everyone else is going to see that of course there's also a bit of an element of comparison and maybe if we can admit it to ourselves a bit of envy here as well a belief that there's someone else out there doing it better so why should we even try I want to tell you this humans have have basically evolved to compare and judge ourselves against others. There have been so many studies showing us that by our third birthday, children start comparing themselves physically to others, and around the age of seven or eight, they start comparing themselves based on characteristics like athleticism, intelligence, humor, and they also
感觉好像有一道巨大的心智光束照在每一个不完美的地方，难道其他人看不到吗？你知道其他人会看到的，当然这里面也有一点比较的元素，如果我们能对自己承认的话，还有一点嫉妒，相信外面有别人做得更好，那我们为什么还要尝试呢。我想告诉你这一点：人类已经进化到会与他人进行比较和判断。有太多的研究表明，到了三岁生日时，儿童就开始在体格上与他人进行比较，到了七八岁左右，他们开始根据运动能力、智力、幽默感等特征进行比较，并且也
start to become competitive. Now, this occurs regardless of culture, country, ethnicity, religion, there is some element of comparison that is hardwired into us psychologically and socially. And it is a huge, massive killer of creative pursuit and passion. Because if you think that someone is already doing it better and that you can't do it unless it's perfect, why even try? So I want you to take that mindset and shift it. because perfectionism is basically procrastination in disguise. So what I want you to do is set yourself a challenge,
开始变得具有竞争力。现在，这与文化、国家、族裔、宗教无关，某种形式的比较是在我们的心理和社会层面硬编码的。它是创意追求和激情的巨大杀手。因为如果你认为别人已经做得更好了，而且除非完美否则你做不到，为什么还要尝试呢？所以我希望你扭转这种心态。因为完美主义基本上是伪装的拖延。所以我想让你做的是给自己设定一个挑战，
a challenge of consistency over perfection. So this is your challenge for the next month. Are you ready? Every day I want you to make something. Even if it is the worst thing you have ever made, even if it is a doodle, even if it is an Instagram post you made on Canva, even if it is one line of a lyric, one line of a book, commit to this one thing that every single day you are going to create, even when you think you don't have time, even when you can't be
一个关于持续性胜过完美的挑战。所以这就是你接下来的一个月的挑战。你准备好了吗？我希望你每天都创造一些东西。即使这是你做过的最糟糕的事情，即使它是一个涂鸦，即使它是你在Canva上制作的一个Instagram帖子，即使它是一行歌词，一本书的一行，承诺这一件事：每天你都要创造，即使当你认为自己没有时间时，即使当你觉得
bothered, that is your challenge. This is the advice I always give people who message me and are like, oh, I want to start a podcast. They always say, what's your biggest tip? And what I say to them is choose one day a week that you want to post and post something every single week, even if it is a three-minute voice memo on your phone. Because this challenge, this activity, gets you past the mental roadblock of needing to be particular and perfect and needing to ensure that everything is polished before you show it to anyone or before you say it's done. You know, there was an amazing paper that I stumbled across in researching this episode
懒得动时，这就是你的挑战。这就是我总是给那些给我发信息说“哦，我想开个播客”的人的建议。他们总是说，你最大的秘诀是什么？我对他们说的是，选择一个你想发帖的日子，每周都发点东西，哪怕是手机上的三分钟语音备忘录。因为这个挑战，这个活动，让你跨越了需要具体和完美、需要确保一切在向任何人展示或说它完成之前都经过精雕细琢的心智路障。你知道，我在为这期节目做研究时偶然发现了一篇很棒的论文，
published in 2015 and it's called Your Best Life, Perfectionism is the Bane of Happiness. And actually, it's not a psychology. paper. It came from an orthopedic surgeon talking about perfectionism in the medical community. And he also dove into this, dove into this discussion around how creativity, joy, inspiration are all so much more abundant when we don't let our perfection, you know, caution or regulate us. When we give ourselves mental permission to make mistakes, even if it's just for 30 days, suddenly you give yourself the gift of an internal environment that is free of judgment and that is full of acceptance.
发表于2015年，名为《你最好的生活，完美主义是幸福的克星》。实际上，它不是一篇心理学论文。它来自一位骨科医生，讨论医学界的完美主义。他还深入探讨了这一讨论，即当我们不让完美（你知道，谨慎或规范）限制我们时，创造力、快乐、灵感会多么丰富。当我们给自己精神上的许可去犯错误，哪怕只是30天，突然间你就送给了自己一个没有审判、充满接纳的内部环境的礼物。
So basically what you say is, okay, you know, we can go back to being a perfectionist and hating ourselves and shaming ourselves for things not being perfect in 30 days. But for this period, this just challenged period, I'm just going to be focused on making. That is my goal. And it really forces you to overcome what is often a mental challenge. to creativity. It also prioritizes regular incremental progress, which I think we all know is a much bigger contributor to success than waiting for the moments where you can just make huge big actions all at once. The person I actually think of when I think of this consistency challenge is a creator
所以基本上你所说的是，好吧，你知道，我们可以在30天后回到做完美主义者、恨自己、因为事情不完美而羞耻的状态。但对于这段时期，这个仅仅是挑战的时期，我只专注于创造。这就是我的目标。它确实迫使你克服通常是创造力的心理挑战。它还优先考虑定期的渐进式进步，我认为我们都知道，这比等待你可以一下子采取巨大行动的时刻对成功的贡献要大得多。当我想到这个持续性挑战时，我实际上想到的一个创作者
called Casey Nystad. And if you know who this is, drop a comment in like the Spotify box right now and say, I know who this is because he is amazing and you might be familiar with him, but if you aren't, check him out. Back in 2014, 2015, I remember watching his videos and at the time he committed to posting a YouTube video every single day for a year. And he went on to do this for I think three to four years. Honestly, it's incredible. Just actually he started off as a really good filmmaker. But over time, you can also see how his craft improves and he starts to have more ideas and not to judge those ideas because he cannot wait to perfect them. He cannot wait for a better idea to come along because part of this challenge was that he only had 24 hours to execute it, to action this idea.
叫做Casey Nystad。如果你知道这是谁，现在就在Spotify的框里留个言说，我知道这是谁，因为他太棒了，你可能很熟悉他，但如果你不熟悉，去看看他。早在2014年、2015年，我记得看他的视频，当时他承诺坚持一年每天都在YouTube上发视频。他后来坚持了，我想有三到四年。老实说，这太不可思议了。实际上他一开始就是一个非常好的电影制作人。但随着时间的推移，你也能看到他的手艺是如何提高的，他开始有更多的想法，并且不去评判这些想法，因为他等不及去完善它们。他不能等待更好的想法出现，因为这个挑战的一部分是他只有24小时来执行它、付诸行动。
So that really put him and from a observer's point of view, it put him in this place of real creative joy and abundance and inspiration and also motivation because it was like, okay, I have this challenge that I've set that kind of makes it fun but also puts the pressure on. and now I have freedom to just make something because it doesn't need to be perfect. So I would really, really ask you to do that. My second tip is also if you are still struggling, it's to create a ritual around whatever creative thing you do, something that can help put you in the right mood and make you feel inspired.
所以这确实把他——从旁观者的角度来看——放在了一个充满真正的创作快乐、丰盛、灵感和动力的地方，因为它就像是，好吧，我设定了这个挑战，这让它变得有趣，但也施加了压力。现在我有自由去创造一些东西，因为它不需要是完美。所以我真的，真的请求你这样做。我的第二个提示也是，如果你仍在挣扎，那就是围绕你做的任何创意事情创造一个仪式，一些可以帮助你进入正确的状态并让你感到受启发的事情。
So this could be lighting a specific incense to prime your brain. I did this when I was writing my book. I would light this specific incense. and I would basically say I have to write for as long as the incense is burning and often by the time it was done I wouldn't even notice because I was so in the zone. You can also create or have a specific place in your house that you can make cozy that is your creative space or have a specific cafe or a desk in your library that you go to create a studio, a class, some environment, some ritual that is associated with the behavior that you want to perform, which is to be created. So this is actually called context-based learning or motivation in psychology, and research has actually discovered this in the benefit that it had by looking at students, specifically high school students who would study in the same spot every day and how those who did, this really helped their brain
所以这可以点燃特定的熏香来启动你的大脑。我在写书时就这样做过。我会点燃这种特定的熏香。基本上我会说，只要熏香在燃烧，我就必须写作，通常到它烧完时我甚至都没有注意到，因为我太投入状态了。你也可以在家里创造或拥有一个特定的地方，你可以把它弄得很温馨，那是你的创意空间，或者有一个特定的咖啡馆或你去的图书馆的桌子去创造一个工作室，一个班级，某种环境，某种与你想表现的行为相关的仪式，那就是具有创造力。这在心理学中实际上被称为基于上下文的学习或动机，研究人员通过观察学生，特别是高中生（他们每天在同一个地方学习），以及这样做如何真正帮助他们的大脑
to actually lock into study mode. So they could get started on whatever they were doing faster and they could maintain that focus state for longer because of the cost. context that they were in, it was priming them to study. Basically, that was their study spot. Their brain was focused on that when they were in that space. And you can use those same principles to lock into the creative process. Some other ritual ideas is having a specific outfit, like painters have a smock or have like overalls, have a specific creative playlist, go for a run before you want to, you know, make music or write or play. Or, paint or do ceramics or whatever it is.
更快地进入学习状态，发现了这一点。因此，由于他们所处的环境，他们可以更快地开始他们正在做的任何事情，并且可以更长时间地保持专注状态，这正在激发他们去学习。基本上，那是他们的学习场所。当他们在那个空间时，他们的大脑就集中在那里。你可以利用那些相同的原则来锁定创作过程。其他一些仪式想法包括穿特定的衣服，就像画家有工作服或背带裤，有一个特定的创意播放列表，在你想要（你知道的）创作、写作、弹奏之前去跑步。
Go for a dance to get into the right headspace. You know, I've used all of these techniques and they really do work. Okay, so I have been rambling for a long time. We're going to take a quick break. But when we return, I have three more valuable tips for you, maybe even a sneaky fourth one actually to do with finances, to do with money. And what I wished, someone had told me about managing my money as a creator and as someone who is pursuing their creative.
或者，去跳舞以进入正确的精神状态。你知道的，我用过所有这些技术，它们确实管用。好吧，我废话了很长时间。我们要休息一下。但当我们回来时，我还有三个对你很有价值的提示，也许甚至还有一个偷偷摸摸的第四个提示，实际上是关于财务的，关于金钱的。以及我希望在我辞去全职工作之前，有人能告诉我作为创作者和追求创意激情的人如何管理我的金钱。所以请留下来。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。
creative passion before I quit my full-time job. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历另一面后，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 T-W-O-Persent。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在 VMA 上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是怎么熬过来的。其中还包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，畅谈20世纪80年代的霹雳娇娃。
To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
坦白说，84年对我意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊快克，但为了让大家清楚，我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在还在讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
对。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。快去 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听“Look Back at It”。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师吉尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。但我们仍在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
因为你觉得在这个世界上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同的信任层次。我希望你纯粹是因为想做一个好人。加入我的节目，我是吉尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, iHeartRadio app search Learn the Hard Way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们将就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序，搜索“Learn The Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives
发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。由此开启了长达数年的真相维权诉讼。你曾多次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要动员一大群网络侦探
to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud, charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. One thing I wish someone had told me when I went full-time with the podcast was actually how lonely it was going to be.
这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听“Love Trapped”播客。我希望有人在我全职做播客时告诉我的一件事，其实是这件事会有多孤独。
About three months in, I really had this realization. You know, I think we tend to romanticize, you know, making our creative project or our creative passion our full-time, and how much freedom we're going to have. We romanticize it and we forget that, you know, there are days where you will not talk to anyone. There were moments when I would not talk to anyone but myself, obviously, until 6pm when my roommates would get home. And I would literally be almost sitting at the door, like panting like a dog, waiting for them to come in and like play with me because I was so starved for connection.
大概三个月的时候，我真的有了这种感悟。你知道的，我认为我们往往会把将我们的创意项目或创意热情变成全职工作这件事浪漫化，觉得我们会拥有多少自由。我们将其浪漫化，却忘记了，你知道的，有些日子里你不会和任何人说话。曾几何时，除了我自己之外，我不会和任何人说话，很显然，直到下午六点我的室友回家。我真的会像狗一样喘着气，几乎坐在门边等他们进来陪我玩，因为我对人际连接渴望到了极点。
So I definitely think that when I was working a full-time corporate job, I took for granted the community that was really innate in that space and which was essentially formed by being trauma bonded or in the trenches together. I remember that same time around three months in, I met up with some friends of mine who were also podcasters and we went up for lunch and I looked at them and I was like, are you guys really, really lonely? And both of them were like, yes, I am so lonely. We are so lonely.
所以我绝对认为，当我做全职公司工作时，我理所当然地认为那种空间里天生就存在的社群感是理所当然的，那种社群感本质上是由创伤粘合或一起经历艰难困苦而形成的。我记得大约在那个时期的三个月左右，我和一些同样是播客的朋友见面，我们出去吃午饭，我看着他们问：“你们真的，真的很孤独吗？”他们两个都说：“是的，我太孤独了。我们太孤独了。”
So tip number three for pursuing your creative passion, whether it's full time, part time, casually, it can get lonely. So create community to keep you inspired and motivated and seen, I guess. So why is this community so important? I think community is just at the foundation, at the core, at the center of our purpose and our needs as humans. And whilst you may have community in terms of family and friends, you can also really benefit from a specific community who are operating towards the same goal or the greater ambition as you are, but also who you can share your problems and your rants with. You know, oh, I'm getting so stuck at this point.
所以，追求创意激情的第三个提示，无论是全职、兼职还是随性而为，它都会变得孤独。所以要建立社群来保持你的灵感、动力，以及被看见的感觉，我想是的。那么为什么这个社群如此重要？我认为社群是作为人类的基础、核心，是我们目标和需求的中心。虽然你可能在家人和朋友方面拥有社群，但你也可以从一个具体的社群中真正受益，他们朝着与你相同的目标或更宏大的抱负努力，同时也是你可以向他们分享你的问题和抱怨的人。你知道的，“噢，我在这点上卡住了。”
I'm getting rejected. I'm struggling with hate online. I'm struggling with this specific technique. Sometimes you want someone who gets it the way that you've experienced it. There is an amazing article by the Harvard Business Review that talks about how community can be a quote survival tool and a way to get through challenging things together. And often a lot of the research on this does look at the workplace.
“我被拒绝了。我在网上遭遇网暴。我在为这个特定的技巧苦恼。”有时你会想要一个能够像你所经历过的那样理解你的人。哈佛商业评论有一篇精彩的文章，讨论了社群如何成为所谓的“生存工具”以及共同度过挑战性事情的方式。而且关于这方面的许多研究确实着眼于职场。
So many studies are done in this space because it's where people have a shared interest, a shared industry, a shared, you know, skill level. But we see time and time again that when you have people you care about and who care about you in a workplace, staff turnover reduces, burnout reduces. juices, people are happier, there is greater employee retention. And we can take that example within the workplace and we can apply it to a creative community. When you make friends and you have so-called colleagues, you will be better for it. That advice obviously means nothing if I don't give you practical tips. So I'll tell you how I would do this if I had to do it again. I would
在这个领域进行了如此多的研究，因为这是人们拥有共同兴趣、共同行业、共同技能水平的地方。但我们一次又一次地看到，当你在职场中拥有你在乎并且在乎你的人时，员工流失率会降低，职业倦怠会减少，人们会更快乐，员工留存率会更高。我们可以把职场中的这个例子应用到一个创意社群中。当你交到朋友并拥有所谓的同事时，你会因此变得更好。如果我不给你实用的建议，那些建议显然就没有意义了。所以我来告诉你，如果让我重来一次，我会怎么做。我会
join workshops. I would go on a retreat, like a small, even if it's a weekend retreat with other people in the space that I want to work in. I would email people who I admire it saying I love their work and ask to collaborate. That's kind of really giving that meme. You know, it's like, why don't you just call Taylor up? But I mean more like people in your city, people in your community who you think are doing cool things. Like network the shit out of it. And Instagram. Instagram. Instagram is like a creative's best friend for building community. And I truly mean that. Follow the people that you love.
参加工作坊。我会去参加静修，比如一个小型的静修，哪怕只是和一个周末的静修，和我想从事的领域的其他人一起。我会给我敬佩的人发邮件，说我喜欢他们的作品并请求合作。这真的有点像那个梗。你知道的，就像，“你为什么不直接打电话给泰勒呢？”但我的意思是更像是你所在城市的人，你社群里你认为在做酷事的人。就像充分利用人脉。还有Instagram。Instagram。Instagram就像是建立社群的创作者的最好朋友。我绝对是认真的。关注你喜欢的人。
Send them a DM saying, oh my, you know, I really admire your work. If you want to get coffee or anything, I'm down. Go to those community events that are centered on your craft. You know,
给他们发私信说，天哪，你知道的，我真的很欣赏你的作品。如果你想喝咖啡什么的，我奉陪。去那些以你的手艺为中心的社群活动。你知道的，
a market. Go to a play. Those kinds of things. And, you know, nowadays I have a small office space that I pay like $50 a week for with four of my friends. And all of them are also podcasters, authors,
集市。去看话剧。诸如此类的事情。而且，你知道，现在我有一个小办公室空间，我和四个朋友每周花大约50美元租下它。他们所有人也都是播客、作家、
designers, writers, and it is so nurturing. I've noticed a massive shift in my mental health, in my emotional well-being, from basically addressing the creative loneliness and the loneliness that is innate in creative life sometimes. I think this is the fourth tip that we're up to now, maybe the fifth, but this one's very, very important. Please don't push yourself to a place of burnout or unenjoyment in pursuit of success. You know, when you start feeling like what you're doing is a burden, take a step back. You and creativity have a relationship. And I got that quote from a book by Elizabeth Gilbert called Big Magic.
设计师、作家，这真的是太滋养了。我注意到我的心理健康、我的情感福祉发生了巨大的转变，基本上解决了创意孤独感，以及有时存在于创意生活中的孤独感。我想这是我们目前的第四个提示，也许是第五个，但这个非常非常重要。请不要在追求成功的过程中把自己逼到精疲力竭或失去乐趣的境地。你知道的，当你开始觉得你正在做的事情是一种负担时，退后一步。你和创造力之间有一种关系。我从伊丽莎白·吉尔伯特（Elizabeth Gilbert）的一本名为《大魔法》（Big Magic）的书里得到了这句话。
How many times have I spoken about that book on this podcast? I cannot tell you. But it's so true, you have a relationship with your creativity. And it needs to be nurtured like a romantic. relationship. You know those times when you and your partner are just constantly getting into arguments or with the parent, you know, or with a sibling or a friend or a roommate, you're just so obviously irritated at each other and you're so obviously frustrated. You don't try and fix that by spending more time together. You take a step back. You go for a walk. You spend the afternoon
我在这档播客里谈论过那本书多少次了？我数不清了。但这是真的，你与你的创造力有一种关系。它需要像恋爱关系一样去滋养。你知道那些时候，你和你的伴侣一直在争吵，或者和父母，你知道的，或者和兄弟姐妹、朋友或室友，你们彼此显然是那么地恼火，显然是那么地沮丧。你不会通过花更多的时间在一起试图解决这个问题。你退后一步。你去散步。你度过一个下午
apart and you have to do the same with whatever it is you're pursuing or creating you need to respect the fact that sometimes you need space and stop pushing in a creative burnout it happens in stages you know stage one is what we call the honeymoon stage where you're kind of enjoying almost that feeling of pushing yourself until you get to stage two stage three chronic stress or stage five which is habitual burnout you are unable to escape a burnout cycle. So make sure you look out for those early signs, especially if you are self-employed, feeling resentful towards what you're doing, not getting joy from it anymore, just wanting to be done, you don't care about the progress, the process or the outcome. Like no part of it is
各自呆着，无论你追求或创造什么，你都必须这样做，你需要尊重这样一个事实，即有时你需要空间，不要再逼迫自己陷入创意倦怠，它分阶段发生，你知道的，第一阶段是我们所说的蜜月期，你几乎有点享受那种推动自己的感觉，直到你进入第二阶段、第三阶段慢性压力，或者第五阶段，也就是习惯性倦怠，你无法逃脱倦怠循环。所以一定要注意这些早期迹象，特别是如果你是自雇人士，对你正在做的事情感到怨恨，从中再也得不到快乐，只想结束，你不在乎进展、过程或结果。就像其中的任何一部分都
happy or enjoyable to you. Stress, headaches, neglecting your own needs. When those things go managed, like it can really destroy your care for something altogether and you never want to do it again. I always use this case study, this example of basketball players and people in the US, basketball players in the US who get paid to play basketball at college who are on scholarships basically. So often like those basketball teams are made up of people who are on scholarships and then people who just play for fun, but they're really, really good. And you want to know the biggest way to guarantee that someone will never play basketball or any sport again after they leave university or after they leave high school.
对你来说并不快乐或愉快。压力、头痛、忽视自己的需求。当这些事情得不到管理时，它真的会彻底毁掉你对某件事的在乎，让你再也不想做这件事了。我总是用这个案例研究，这个关于篮球运动员和美国人的例子，美国拿奖学金的大学生篮球运动员基本上靠打篮球拿薪水。通常那些篮球队是由拿奖学金的人和那些为了好玩而打球但真的非常非常厉害的人组成的。你想知道如何确保一个人在离开大学或离开高中后绝不再打篮球或任何运动的最大方法是什么吗？
It is to force them to play and to make them feel like they are obligated to play, to not give them space between them and the sport. And the same thing goes for your creative endeavor. I would also say try different mediums to keep it fun. Like we said, creativity thrives on rest and novelty as well. So if you're a jewelry maker, try ceramics for a bit. If you do illustrations, try doing some coloring in. I recently bought these adult coloring in books.
那就是强迫他们打球，让他们觉得他们有义务打球，不给他们自己和这项运动之间留出空间。你的创意努力也是如此。我还要说，尝试不同的媒介来保持乐趣。正如我们所说，创造力靠休息和新鲜感蓬勃发展。所以如果你是一个珠宝制造商，试着做一会儿陶瓷。如果你做插图，尝试做一些填色。我最近买着玩这些成人填色书。
They're really, really simple. And like, I just cannot explain how much joy this brings me in how when I'm doing it, I get into this real flow state in my mind comes up with so many other ideas. If you play trumpet, maybe try writing the lyrics to a song. song. Keep those creative neural pathways active and alive and not entirely consumed and restricted by the need to produce and be successful in your chosen area and to basically just like keep trying to drag along an exhausted horse. I don't think that's the metaphor but I think you know what I mean. Make sure that you keep it light and fun at times even when things are getting
它们真的非常非常简单，而且，我简直无法解释这给我带来了多少快乐，当我在做这件事时，我进入了一种真正的沉浸状态，我的脑海中会涌现出许许多多的其他想法。如果你吹小号，也许可以试着给一首歌写歌词。歌词。保持这些创造性的神经通路活跃和存活，而不是完全被你在你选择的领域中生产和成功的需求所吞噬和限制，基本上就像一直拖着一匹精疲力竭的马前行。我觉得这不是那个比喻，但我想你明白我的意思。确保你有时保持轻松和有趣，即使事情变得
stressful. Let's finally talk about the big end. Let's talk about money. We cannot talk about pursuing our creative passion without talking about how that is going to influence our relationship to our finances. Now, if you want to know specifically the psychology about this and what your money language might be and the psychology behind your relationship with money, we have a full episode on that. It's titled how money impacts our mental health. I think it's episode 226. So if you're looking for the psychology, go and listen to that episode after this. But I specifically want to talk like practical advice that I have. Practical advice for managing your money in your 20s as someone who also wants to pursue their passion project. This is the biggest tip I have. Save more money than you think you will need.
有压力。让我们最后谈谈大结局。我们来谈谈钱。我们在谈论追求创意激情时，不可能不谈论它将如何影响我们与财务的关系。现在，如果你想具体了解这背后的心理学、你的金钱语言可能是什么，以及你与金钱关系背后的心理学，我们有一期完整的节目专门探讨这个。它的标题是“金钱如何影响我们的心理健康”。我想这是第226集。所以如果你在寻找心理学方面的探讨，听完这集后去听听那一集吧。但我特别想谈谈我拥有的实际建议。作为也想追求自己激情项目的人，在20岁时管理金钱的实用建议。这是我给出的最大建议：存比你想象中需要的更多的钱。
do not immediately quit your job go part time before you quit your job this is a big one the big biggest piece of advice if things are taking off for you if you're really really excited just wait a couple of months and just go part time and just see how you adjust to it and save as much money as you can before you quit the stable job something that i truly believe in it's a huge core part of my belief system about how to approach our 20s is that you can still take risks without them necessarily being spontaneous. Like you can take a calculated risk. You can think through the risk that you want to make, be that quitting your job, doing your creative passion full time. Just make sure that you have thought it through. Put money aside continually through that period.
不要马上辞职，在辞职前先做兼职，这是一个重大建议，最大的建议，如果你的事情正在起飞，如果你真的非常非常兴奋，只需等上几个月，先做兼职，看看你是如何适应它的，在辞掉稳定工作之前尽可能多存钱。我真正相信的一件事，是我关于如何对待我们20岁的人生观的一个巨大核心部分，那就是你仍然可以冒险，而不需要它们一定是随兴而至的。就像你可以进行计算好的风险一样。你可以仔细考虑你想承担的风险，无论是辞职还是全职做你的创意激情。只要确保你已经仔细考虑过了。在这段时期内持续把钱存起来。
My rule of thumb I had, and this is not necessarily what you've. should do but I had four months of income saved up before I quit because I was like if this totally goes to shit and I lose my interest in this I just suddenly don't want this to be my job and I can't make money off of it at least I have a four month buffer to kind of figure things out that was really actually very important for me because I ended up you know not really making as like not really getting paid for different contracts for a while. So it was good to have that money that I could rest back on. And as someone who is self-employed, this is more as a tip for people who are already doing their creative passion full-time. Put money into your retirement savings. Something that I think
我的经验法则是——这不一定是你应该做的——我在辞职前存了四个月的收入，因为我想，如果这彻底搞砸了，我失去了对这玩意的兴趣，我突然不想让这成为我的工作了，而且我从这上面赚不到钱，至少我还有四个月的缓冲期来弄清楚事情。这对我来说实际上非常重要，因为我最后发现（你知道的），有一段时间并没有真正从不同的合同中赚到多少钱，也没有真正拿到报酬。所以手头有那些可以依靠的钱真是太好了。作为一个自雇人士，这更多的是给那些已经全职从事创意激情的人的建议。把钱存入你的退休储蓄中。我觉得我们
we struggle with in our 20s is thinking long term. We only tend to do it when we're really stressed. You know, we worry about the future and we worry where we're going to be and who we're going to be with and are we going to be successful. We don't necessarily think about what it's going to be like to be 65 and no longer really be able to work a job and how we're going to deal with that. I'm so fortunate that I live in Australia where we have something called Super, which is like mandatory retirement saving from your employer. But when you're self-employed, that's your job. So make sure that you continue to do that. and as you're getting established as an artist, as a musician, as a writer, as any of those, you know, any of those careers and areas, insert your own, really ask your family and friends to support your work as well.
在20岁时挣扎的一件事就是进行长远思考。我们往往只有在压力非常大的时候才会这样做。你知道的，我们担心未来，我们担心我们会去哪里，我们会和谁在一起，我们会成功吗。我们不一定在想65岁时会是什么样子，不再真正能够做一份工作，我们将如何应对这种情况。我很幸运，我住在澳大利亚，我们有一种叫做 Super 的东西，也就是雇主提供的强制性退休储蓄。但当你是个体经营者时，这就是你的工作。所以请确保你继续这样做。当你作为一个艺术家、一个音乐家、一个作家、或者任何这些职业和领域建立起声誉时（代入你自己的职业），一定要请求你的家人和朋友也支持你的作品。
Now, that can mean financially. That can mean, hey, can you buy my poetry book? Can you come to my reading? Can you come to my stand-up show? Can you pay for a ticket? But also, emotionally and in their social networks. So I got a really amazing question from someone the other day on Instagram, which was, you know, how do I start out as an artist who wants to sell their art online? And I said to them, please ask your family and your friends to share it wide and share it loudly. Ask your friends to just post a story of something that you've made for them or with a link to your Instagram page or to your Etsy or to your Shopify, share your song, share whatever it is.
现在，这可能意味着在经济上支持。这可能意味着，嘿，你能买我的诗集吗？你能来我的朗诵会吗？你能来我的单口喜剧秀吗？你能买张票吗？但这也意味着在情感上和他们的社交网络上支持。所以前几天我在 Instagram 上收到了一个非常棒的问题，那就是，“作为一个想在网上卖艺术品的艺术家，我该如何起步？”我对他们说，请让你的家人和朋友广泛地、大声地分享它。让你的朋友发布一张他们为你制作的或是用你的 Instagram 页面链接、你的 Etsy 或你的 Shopify 链接制作的东西的故事，分享你的歌，分享无论是什麽。
I think that word of mouth in the creative community and in the creative space is so powerful and also psychologically. Like who do we trust the most? It's the people who we know. So by asking your friends to share on Instagram, to share on Facebook, to share on LinkedIn, whatever it is, you know, people who follow them, who know them
我认为创意社群和创意空间中的口碑是非常强大的，而且在心理上也是如此。我们最信任谁？是我们认识的人。所以通过让你的朋友在 Instagram 上分享，在 Facebook 上分享，在 LinkedIn 上分享，无论是什么平台，你知道的，关注他们、了解他们的人
will be like, oh, I trust their opinion. and, you know, I care about what they care about. So maybe I'll like this thing. Maybe I want to buy something from this person. Maybe I'll want to listen to this podcast, listen to this music. That is just like a final tip that I really wanted to share. But I also just want to finish this episode by saying, I think that this is the time you should be doing it.
会觉得，“哦，我信任他们的观点，而且我在乎他们在乎的事情。”所以也许我会喜欢这个东西。也许我想从这个人这里买点东西。也许我想听这个播客，听这段音乐。这只是我真的很想分享的最后一个提示。但我也想以这样一句话来结束本集：我认为这是你应该去做的时刻。
In your 20s, you have so much freedom and space to make mistakes. And the most time you will ever have to fix those mistakes, if things really go south, if your creative passion really fair, fails, well, you are never going to have more time than you have now to make up for it. I also think that you don't want to be in a situation in 30 years where it's harder to pursue your creative entrepreneurial passion and realize that you wish you'd done it sooner. The biggest regret that we experience is what we call inaction regret. It's regret over not doing something.
在你的20岁，你有那么多的自由和空间去犯错。而且，如果事情真的急转直下，如果你的创意激情真的失败了，你将拥有最多的时间来纠正这些错误，你永远不会有比现在更多的时间来弥补它。我也认为，你不会希望在30年后陷入这样一种境地：那时更难去追求你的创意创业激情，并且意识到你希望自己早点这么做。我们经历过的最大的遗憾是我们所称的“不作为遗憾”。这是对没有做某事而产生的遗憾。
So the best way to avoid that kind of regret is to surprise, surprise, do the thing. Do the scary thing, do the hard thing, do the thing that the naysayers say you can't do. Do it small and then medium and then big, but just do it. So I hope this episode has been, if nothing else, inspiring. Hopefully you've actually gotten some practical tips from this episode as well, something that you can put into action. I really want to hear about this challenge that I'm setting for you guys, your 30-day challenge to make something every single day.
所以避免这种遗憾的最好方法是，出人意料地，去做那件事。去做那件可怕的事，做那件困难的事，做那些唱反调的人说你做不到的事。从小到大，从小到中再到大，但只管去做。所以我希望这期节目哪怕没有别的，也能给你带来启发。希望你确实也从这期节目中得到了一些实用的建议，一些你可以付诸行动的东西。我真的很想听到关于我给你们设定的这个挑战的消息，你们每天创造一些东西的30天挑战。
If you actually end up doing it, please, DM me on Instagram, I'm going to give you huge kudos. And make sure that you are following along with the podcast if you're a new listener. If you're an old listener, we would love to hear from you, but also we would love to have you rate the podcast five stars, leave a nice review if you feel called to do so. It really does help the show grow and reach you people. It helps make my creative dreams a reality as well, speaking of that. I also want to invite you to send in any episode suggestions that you might have. my DMs on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast, are always open to hear from you guys if you have
如果你真的完成了它，请在 Instagram 上私信我，我会给你大大的赞许。如果你是新听众，请确保继续关注这个播客。如果你是老听众，我们很乐意听到你的反馈，但我们也希望你能给这个播客打五星好评，如果你觉得有必要的话，请留下一个好评。这确实有助于节目的成长并接触到新的人。说到这里，它也有助于让我的创意梦想变成现实。我也想邀请你发送你可能有的任何节目建议。我在 Instagram 上的私信（账号为 That Psychology Podcast）随时向你们开放，如果你对本期节目有任何评论，或者希望我围绕这个主题或想法制作任何后续节目，
any comments on this episode or any further episodes that you want to want me to do on this topic or this idea. So I would love to hear from you. But until next time, good luck with your creative passion. Stay safe, stay kind, be gentle with yourselves. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
我很乐意听到你们的声音。但直到下一次，祝你的创意激情好运。保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在
in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast.
我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即 TWO%，在 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在“Look Back at It”播客中。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends,
对1979年来说，那对我是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·杰伊，我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试着与我们的朋友、
fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何在其中生存下来的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听“Look Back at It”。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都真的不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听“Learn the Hard Way”。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾多次篡改这份特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要动员一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
格雷格，一个同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是 Love Trapped。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或任何你收听播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。这是一档 iHeart 播客。人类出品，必属精品。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。